jurors in San Francisco on Monday are
set to resume deliberations on the
alleged killer of Kate Steinle a five
times deported illegal immigrant from
Mexico who prosecutors say gunned down
thirty two-year-old Kate on a San
Francisco pier in July of 2015 the
shooting sparked a national debate about
San Francisco and other liberal big
cities sanctuary policies of refusing to
cooperate with the federal government on
immigration matters one person who
doesn't seem to have a problem with
sanctuary cities is far-left San
Francisco Federal Judge William auric
earlier this week he issued a permanent
block on president Trump's executive
order that seeks to withdraw some
federal funding to sanctuary cities
former Republican congressman and Fox
News contributor jason Chaffetz had some
wise words on how to respond to the
judge's ruling there's a way to actually
solve this problem because if he's
saying that Congress has not given the
president the proper authorization guess
what the reauthorization for all the
funding of the federal government moving
forward has to happen by December 8th
one or two sentences placed into that
funding bill which will pass will solve
this problem give the president the
authority joining us now for reaction in
Fort Worth Texas is immigration attorney
Francisco Hernandez and in Chicago
Fox News contributor Steve Cortes I am
good Francisco so let me start with you
in Alabama judge Moore when he was not
cooperating with the federal government
with regards to enforcing gay marriage
law he got shut down immediately so why
is it okay for San Francisco officials
to not cooperate with federal
immigration law well it's a completely
different subject in San Francisco
you're dealing with a money issue who's
going to pay for people that are going
to be incarcerated to honor the federal
ice holes it's a financial issue as well
in terms of marriage to be paid for
marriage licensing and that was what the
whole beef was I don't know that that
had to do with the Equal Protection
Clause of the United States Constitution
but there's still a financial component
I'm saying tell me what the financial
component of that is when you go to the
core
house you have to pay marriage licensing
fees and when you form a union you know
you're taxed as a couple you file
jointly that kind of thing no no it's a
$25 filing fee for a marriage
certificate really that's that's a
completely different issue let me give
you another analogy hold on so if what
about a gun shop in Texas and someone
comes in to buy a gun and they don't
feel like delivering the guy's name to
the federal background database they
don't believe in it and they're going to
resist and not cooperate with the feds
on background checks and just sell the
guy a gun how is that different than San
Francisco there's two issues well
there's two issues one it is a private
company okay and it is a criminal
offense not to submit the name in the
case of San Francisco there is no such
thing as a sanctuary city they don't
accept is it's a it's a political
phantom everybody's afraid of it but
nobody can see it what you're talking
about is if the immigration Customs
Enforcement Agency once the jail to hold
someone for whatever reason they sent a
piece of paper and and the cities are
wanting to know who's going to pay for
the incarceration cost for all these
folks they're supposedly they could pick
up any time they want all right let's
get in here what are you thinking about
that to get in here because you're just
you are lying that is not the truth what
happened in San Francisco in this matter
Johnny with in this case specifically
with Kate Steinle
okay her killer this wasn't just bad
luck this wasn't just an unfortunate
circumstance her killer was detained
weeks before five times deported
previously obtained by the San Francisco
by the San Francisco Police Department
ice issued a detainer which is the legal
request to have custody of him to deport
him for the sixth time which is absurd
in and of itself and a San Francisco
Police Department let me talk and the
San Francisco Police Department because
of the awful liberal policy of that city
to protect illegal immigrants over the
rights of legal US citizens decided to
ignore the ice detainer he was released
in December says no weeks later he
killed a beautiful young American in
cold blood right who died in her
father's arms yeah I mean San Francisco
city officials have blood on their hands
princess tragedy of
roll politics over common sense and
common decency quite frankly immigration
could have picked him up in LA County
before they took him to San Francisco
immigration ice could have taken the
first day he stepped foot in San
Francisco the federal government there's
not only a separation of a city yes she
did County how is this know when the
five times deported prints they get the
fingerprints from the federal government
they already know they're there go pick
them up now they need an immigration
hold taste Francisco every day if
someone's roaming around the city of San
Francisco the feds have no idea he's
there until he gets picked up if he gets
big run his fingerprints yeah so he gets
picked on the Fed they run the
fingerprints and then the city of San
Francisco's responsibility is to then
report that to ice and if I says yeah
hold on ice they don't hold them up
today I have blood on their hands it's
no it's not if they have to hold them
for 48 hours
if the ice does not pick them up with it
after the 48 hours from the immigration
hold they don't have a legal reason to
hold somebody but then again let's
remember this guy they have a legal
reason to hold somebody because the feds
say hold them Jesse before we get Mayer
to much of the exact details of this
case and I think by the way they
completely argue against sanctuary
cities but before we get mired too much
in the details here in the minutiae of
this specific case the principles more
important and I think cities like
Chicago where I am like San Francisco
these cities have willfully and I'm glad
you mentioned Alabama Jesse because they
remind me a lot of George Wallace in the
1960s with these local mayors and some
of the governor's are doing is saying to
the federal government we don't want to
obey your laws for our own narrow
political interests for our own
politically correct agenda and so we're
gonna just choose to ignore your laws
just as the southern governors chose to
ignore civil rights laws well guess what
federal law is paramount particularly
when it comes to immigration and the
safety of the citizens of the United
States of Chicago of San Francisco of
cities all over this country the city
their safety is being jeopardized
because of a narrow politically correct
liberal political agenda and by the way
talk to cops on the beat as I do here in
Chicago they want to cooperate the ice
of course they do they have to help
federal law in fact Francisco thirty
Seconds will give you the last word go
ahead guys there is no way that any city
state county can oppose the federal
government okay guys if we want to fix
this let's get on with fixing
immigration let's get on with the
important thing about this country but
if we've got to talk about these holes
these holes are good for 48 hours they
do not have authority to hold them after
48 hours that's how they're saying is
we're following the hold 48 hour rule
that immigration put in place now guys
let's move on immigration reform and
stop talking about this well let's move
on and build the wall that he wouldn't
have come back across the border final
time guys about a running man